[Music]
welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my new star wars the
mandalorian season 2 teaser video they
just dropped a bunch of new previews
for season 2. we got some first looks at
the characters so we'll break it all
down there's a whole bunch of easter
eggs and they talked about what's going
on
in each of the episodes if you're new to
the channel of course i'll be doing
videos for all the episodes be sure to
subscribe to get everything we'll do a
new amazon giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber
and let me know what you're most hyped
up about for season two
starting with the big stuff first i'll
just number these as we go along to all
the easter eggs
john favreau spent a lot of time
referencing empire strikes back when
talking about the story of season two
just in terms of the way things move
the references that they're going for
because he revealed that season one was
mostly based
on the first act just the first act of
star wars episode iv a new hope so
they're basically moving into empire
strikes back territory in terms of what
they're doing with the story
really good example of that is the boba
fett of it all boba fett may have
appeared for the first time in the
christmas special but his first
canonical appearance
in a live action was empire strikes back
the second movie now he's showing up in
the second season of the mandalorian so
it also implies that some of the themes
and tone of empire strikes back will
influence the events of the mandalorian
season 2 episodes
when you're also trying to theorycraft
about how they're going to end season 2
think about the way that they ended
empire strikes back they also confirmed
that the episodes themselves will feel
more connected than they were during the
season 1 episodes each of the season 1
episodes were mostly different bounties
like a series of one-off adventures with
a very very loose continuity tying them
together as he was trying to protect
baby yoda there were only a few
characters that appeared in multiple
episodes as part of the overarching plot
and only a few
episodes themselves that were solely
dedicated to that main plot
it just sounds like season two is going
to be way more serialized and they did
say that the scope of the story gets
so much bigger whereas in season one
they were mostly local to a couple
planets
you didn't really see much from the
remnants of the empire moff gideon's
faction or the new republic
they say that season two will invoke a
lot more characters and larger
storytelling more lore that gets into
the ahsoka of it all the boba fett
mob gideon dealing with his backstory
the lore behind the mandalorians in the
darksaber
but the first new scene here that they
dropped is mando cara dune
and grief karga looking like they're in
an imperial facility or a ship just
looking at the wall the control panel
behind them
imperial gray very sterile looking very
identifiable
it's hard to tell though if they're on a
planet in a building in an imperial
facility or if they're on
someone's ship like if this is them on
one of moff gideon's imperial ships
also if you look at grief karga's color
scheme here this actually kind of
reminds me of anakin and palpatine's
clothes and revenge of the sith with the
mixture of reds and blacks he's not evil
himself
but carl weathers did say we learned
more about his backstory during season
two all we learned about him during
season one from moff gideon when he was
reading off their
rap sheets and their backstories was
that he used to be an administrator like
a local magistrate that was disgraced
living on navarro before he
started running the batting hunters
guild of course there are several
previews and scenes of mando and baby
yoda that they dropped on what looks
like tatooine for the most part
this is them chilling out in town
looking like they're just waiting for
someone
baby yoda is sitting closer to eye level
the reason why they actually do that
practically from the way that they film
things
is so that they can frame the shot with
mando and also have baby yoda in the
scene without having to cut to a
different shot of him standing at boot
level on the ground
like you're seeing both of their faces
in the same shot without him having to
pick him up and carry him around
but notice the posture pedro pascal
actually did say that he evolved the way
that he performs the mandalorian when
he's underneath all that armor
because a lot of it just involves his
body language because you can't
see his face you can't see his mouth
move and usually most audiences look to
that first when they're trying to get
into a character
this is cara dune it actually seems like
it's on a different planet because the
background architecture and color scheme
are totally different
she seems like a lot of her time during
season two is spent mostly around
navarro now with greek karga
since she accepted his offer to become
his enforcer in exchange for him helping
clear her record with the new republic
because her whole thing was that she was
still marked as a deserter when she
joined them she used to be a new
republic shock trooper but then deserted
i can't tell if this is grief karga on a
ship or still on navarro i'm assuming
this is him just back on navarro during
a meeting with mando or someone else
he didn't leave the planet during season
one so i don't know if that trend is
going to continue into season 2
but his activities running the bounty
hunters guild don't really call for him
to fly all over the galaxy himself so
much
this is the first look at moff gideon in
season 2. he seems like he's on the
bridge of what is probably his
imperial star destroyer flagship
giancarlo esposito did talk a lot about
what's going on with him during season 2
so i'll get into that
he didn't say how big the force he
commands is or how many ships he has in
his fleet but it's probably pretty
decent size
you can just tell from the lights in the
control bank in the background it's just
that signature look of an imperial
capital ship
the really cool thing he said about his
storyline during season two is that he'd
be going toe to toe with mando like they
would actually be having one-on-one
fights with the darksaber
he referred to their fights as iconic
battles but he also said that he'd be
manipulating the mando
mentally he said and i'm quoting him
maybe there's an opportunity to get him
to fight some battles
for me you may think i'm the villain i'm
trying to harness some energy and some
powers for a path
that could be best for all you get to
see him be somewhat diplomatic
and more of a manipulator so i think
that's just making references to emperor
palpatine trying to move chess pieces
around the galactic board manipulating
people into doing things for him without
realizing it
that just implies that he's going to try
and get mando to take care of some
problems for him
in the territory that he's trying to
control in and around navarro
he does refer to the darksaber as a
lightsaber there are a lot of people i
think that were confused about that
maybe if you didn't watch the clone wars
or you're not really up on star wars
lore
the dark saber really is just a
different type of lightsaber that was
created by an ancient mandalorian the
very first mandalorian to ever become a
jedi
new jedi each make their own lightsabers
as just part of the custom but when it
came time for this first mandalorian
jedi to make his lightsaber
he used a different type of crystal
different type of architecture so it has
very different properties from other
lightsabers but it is itself just
another different type of lightsaber you
don't actually have to be force
sensitive to use it but maf gideon did
imply that he himself has a strange
connection to the force which i think
just implies that he himself is force
sensitive on some level but was never
trained as a jedi
when he was talking about the resources
that moff gideon has he says
hint hint larger vehicle i think he's
just talking about an imperial star
destroyer because that would be the
go-to
thing an imperial moth would want in the
remnants of the empire
if you're trying to grasp for resources
that would be one of the first things
that you would go for
this is just a different scene amando
and baby yoda also on tatooine notice
him here in the little pouch on the back
of the speeder
it seems like it has some tracking
device attached to it probably just as a
security measure
someone put a bell on that kid in case
he runs off the speeder bike is the same
model
of speeder bike that they were using
during season 1 episode 5
and all the sand in the background the
color of the buildings there's also the
scene of the tuscan raider on his bantha
which should be a dead giveaway for
tatooine
this is all probably something to do
with the boba fett's storyline because
that's the last place that we saw him
in episode 5 in that in credit scene
with mingna's body there's no way of
knowing which episodes these all come
from but i'm assuming they're from the
earlier episodes since they
probably wouldn't want to give away any
big spoilers from where they go in the
later episodes
other than the general moff gideon
battles that they get into probably
towards the end of the season
this background landscape with all the
volcanic rock makes most people think of
mustafar but i think it's just meant to
reference the volcanic landscape from
navarro at the end of last season
and this is just mando and baby yoda
looking like they're walking around on
foot normally with him riding that same
pouch from the end of season one
during the entertainment weekly article
they confirm rosario dawson ahsoka tano
katie sackoff boca tan crees
temerera morrison is boba fett timothy
oliphant and michael bain
i believe that michael baine is playing
another older bounty hunter i don't know
if he's playing someone big from the
star wars canon though
and for those of you that are hoping
that at some point dave filoni himself
within the world of star wars
and lucasfilm will take a bigger
supervisory role john favreau actually
did say how critical
dave filoni was to the mandalorian
season one going so well
they said that when they were working on
stories together he was as you would
expect the sort of lore keeper the
person
who kept it being star wars they also
said that in addition to spending a lot
of time talking about the movies because
obviously the series takes a lot of
inspiration from the original trilogy
they also spent a lot of time talking
about the clone wars
when they were making the episodes you
could see some of that reflected in the
easter eggs like you have the death
watch mandalorians from the clone wars
showing up in all the mandalorian
flashbacks during the period that covers
the clone wars
one of the other big things they said
that has changed between season one and
season two
is just the way they use baby yoda in
the episodes and practically the way
they film him
this is the during season one they just
weren't sure how much to use him
but because everything went so well now
they're actually structuring
a lot of the way that they filmed things
around baby yoda he's almost like the
centerpiece the real
star of the show but what's probably
gonna happen in the next two weeks or so
they'll drop the official season two
trailer of course i'll do a video for
that when it drops there's also supposed
to be the dune trailer tomorrow so as
long as you have alerts enabled for my
channel you'll see all those videos when
i post them
and there will be more mandalorian bonus
videos before season 2 episodes get here
the whole season is starting october
30th so it's not that far away
wait wait for everything click here for
all my mandalorian season 2
and season 1 episode videos and click
here for my new chadwick boseman
marvel black panther video thank you so
much for watching
everyone stay safe i'll see you guys
tonight
you